a 7 horas en carro el suroeste de túnez
cerca de la frontera con Argelia el Shot
el herito el mayor lago Salado del
magreb acoge la edición número 13 de la
semana de la moda de túnez y a su
diseñador más joven
Gandhi Tiene 18 años y todavía está en
el colegio
[Música]
Ah no no eso no es mío
Era realmente una colección sobre la
juventud toresina sobre el tercer mundo
porque hay una escena oculta en Tunes
pero no todo el mundo conoce este lado
misterioso de túnez
de la juventud tunecina y quería rendir
homenaje a esta comunidad donde ground
que tanto me fascina
porque he formado parte de ella durante
mucho tiempo
tradicional y tengo mucho respeto por la
artesanía tunecina
y estas pocas piezas en las que trabajé
muy poco tiempo quería realmente
mostrarlas en la semana de la moda
porque sabía que habría Muchos medios de
comunicación internacionales
semana de la moda en túnez un Crisol de
propuestas de moda
Josh Racing es una escena transformarse
en el instituto de estudios avanzados de
Kuwait fundó su casa de moda en 2015 en
campala uganda antes de volver a
instalarse en Tunes para desarrollar
piezas únicas
este tejido se llama ayek en túnez o
tarifa es Antiguo se podía encontrar en
todo el norte de África en Argelia túnez
Marruecos e incluso en España
las mujeres solían llevarlo todo el
tiempo
talifa significa envolverse se envolvían
en un ayer Sobre todo si se iban lejos
de casa sin sus maridos o hijos es una
mezcla de lana algodón y Lino hoy en día
nadie lo utiliza de esta manera
pero es la primera vez que se utiliza en
la costura
porque normalmente se para cortinas o
alfombras junto a la cama para la
decoración de interiores
el evento también destaca el trabajo de
los estudiantes dirigidos por sus
profesores los aprendices de estilistas
tenían que interpretar una pieza mítica
la chaqueta Safari
para el tema Safari elegimos vaqueros de
color azul
para Añadir un toque de agua en el
desierto son los contrastes
de hecho los desiertos los contrastes
entre los desiertos y el agua y cómo se
siente por dentro
me siento increíblemente cómoda sexy
hay un toque de ropa de calle y creo que
es bastante moderno haber elegido esa
dirección
un toque feminismo con un toque sexy me
encanta
[Música]
cuáles son sus mayores retos en este
proyecto
es mayor reto para todos los estudiantes
son los productos naturales
Así que nuestros estudiantes siempre
intentan encontrar una alternativa
tengo algunos estudiantes que realmente
han utilizado las hierbas la cúrcuma el
café y la arena
Así que nuestros estudiantes siempre
intentan encontrar una alternativa
en Ucrania ahora trabaja en tiflis
Georgia para ella una semana de la moda
consiste sobre todo en conocer a los
compradores
si las personas clave y los compradores
deberían estar interesados en mi
colección Porque encaja tanto con la
época como con su sistema de valores
personales Así que creo que sí
encontraré compradores de hecho después
del espectáculo ya he recibido consulta
pero para todos ellos lo más importante
aquí en este marco excepcional es el
impacto visual que puede tener su
colección Entonces
era tan puro y limpio y lo que
representa Mi trabajo es el minimalismo
Así que el lugar era Perfecto perfecto
para la luz
la luz que había en el momento de mi
espectáculo
todo esto respecto la esencia de mi
colección
invitada por el festival a diseñadora
ucraniana Cristina lapson no podía
abandonar el beef emplea su diseñadora
para que viniera a presentar su
colección
más de tres días de viaje no importa el
tiempo que tarde siempre que tenga la
imagen
Porque necesitamos sesiones de fotos de
video carretes para Instagram para
nuestra página web
y luego de todos estos lugares hermosos
locos naturales como el desierto o el
Oasis
todos estos lugares producen muy buenos
contrastes
moda Europea y moda africana exótica
naturaleza africana naturaleza
naturaleza y moda en conjunto esto
produce algo increíble
a pesar de una situación económica
desastrosa y una cruel falta de medios
la semana de la moda de túnez logró
vender su exotismo sus tradiciones y su
diversidad
[Música]